oh and then in the bed later oh man too
bad we missed out on cooking things oh
let's get Taco Bell you
won't Montage eating Taco Bell no
no no no no no no and then candle feeds
the flame oh God [__] talk about
this oh yeah we're making our dreams
you know
drunk
[Music]
we started yeah I was so nervous to talk
about oh do you want to have your thing
yeah I did I wanted to exhibit it the
guy's name is Mark oh does everybody see
my nose yo I see it okay it actually
makes you sound different dude I know
because it clears my nostrilisimos and
when it clears my nostrilisimos I
feel better you guys can see it because
you see that my nostrils look big like
they're flaring up uh you see the little
rubber thing on the bottom it's clear
you can't really tell but if you know me
you can tell because I look different
it opens up my nostrilisimos so I can
breathe everything would be so boring if
you just didn't say I'm not sure this
emotional well I did say nostrilisimos
because I know how to entertain people
astralisimo is a [__] Italian psychic
all right taking it out now okay
um I mean you know hiding hiding to it
magic trick magic trick uh uh yeah well
uh I tell you what dude
um this is lifeline and we have a new
episode of Lifeline today and it's
amazing so that's great uh go to
chrisley.com to get tickets I'm on tour
right when does this one come out I
gotta be in uh Canada that's pretty much
sold out except for Ottawa I think
um out of what the frig get tickets to
everybody what the frick are you
thinking I'll be in Cleveland and I will
be in
um
yeah keep it moving obviously you know
because it's already Pittsburgh
um Detroit Orlando
Fort Myers Richmond Virginia that's the
one I can remember Baltimore
Philadelphia and Reading Pennsylvania
chrisley.com get tickets like And
subscribe we'd love it if you uh were a
uh
um what do you call it on Lifeline
luxury we got patreon.com Lifeline
luxury uh that's where we got our our um
other well it's this podcast just within
Batman and no no uh what do you call it
uh guest submissions the thing about
that show is that it keeps getting
better the very last episode which might
be the second or last by the time this
airs
um was
Bellissimo yeah all right a lot of
isimos and then
um uh you can go to get the one-on-one
advice session with Matt at matalia.com
and send us a submission by clicking the
thing in the below in the link
um or in the merch lifelinemirch.com
gotta get the merch gotta get every
piece of the merch otherwise you don't
count uh well that's very very hardcore
if they don't count in what life you
don't count in my heart well if you have
a couple you're doing good you're
getting close to counting in my heart if
you have them all you count
honestly my beloved you're among my both
not only do they count they're one of
your beloveds yeah okay so if you want
to match beloveds exactly yeah so
uh oh I didn't bring the painting
somebody painted us oh I saw I saw it
something that's cool
I'll bring it uh two things one you
forget Richmond which bothers me because
Richmond should be the one that you
remember because it's the word that a
lot of people are saying now because
that guy Oliver Anthony who sings rich
men north of Richmond is that where I'm
gonna be yeah so you're gonna be right
there if you go north you better watch
out the rich men will try to take all of
your money Richmond they will tax you
and there will be like he said as he
says people who are five foot three and
three hundred pounds on welfare trying
to take your money yep that's the lyrics
what if that was how it was and it
wasn't that they were like trying to go
through the system to take get money
they were literally like hey it's
children's right and then they would
take it and then roll away wow I mean is
there anyone that's five three and three
hundred pounds in his song There are do
you think that there is though I mean at
least one right yeah there's got to be a
handful that'd be like uh what do you
call it the um uh spawns villain
violator violator yeah violator violator
was the scariest comic book yeah he was
yeah and even John leguizama was scary
when he did it he was he was really good
in it John that was almost a good actor
dude yeah he is there was uh there was
uh
my whole life kind of like loving life
living life hello I don't know I love
and life there was a line from something
that I didn't know no you're gonna ask
people to know no I I found out
and don't act like that would be bad if
I did that though well just like you
know use Google for the thing not our
audience right obviously I would try it
okay anyway somebody saved my life on
house guests you don't need to save my
life this time because I figured it out
okay on my own thanks to everybody else
so it was a villain saying the the name
Kincaid like this
isn't that RoboCop no it was the cartoon
spawn violator oh violator was saying
and when I discovered what it was
actually a friend of mine showed it to
me because oh I needed help and he did
it for me thank you well so far thank
you Ben so far that's the most this is
the most boring the podcast has ever
been now listen to this though so and
that's fine because we got our die hards
you know what I'm saying no we got her
die hards and they're still listening
but this is the most boring the podcast
has ever been
you know what I mean we're talking about
Kincaid
I don't even remember honestly so that's
great talk about Oliver Anthony and
everybody else is talking about that so
it's not that bad that is true and
Oliver Anthony is a good singer and he's
a good singer everybody's mad at him now
though because he called America a
melting pot
and all the people who were supporting
him and loving him on the road
yeah like that's not why is that even
controversial use a Melting Pot it just
is whether you like it yeah there's a
lot of people from a lot of different
places I mean that was Reagan's whole
thing like if you're on the right you
love Reagan come on everybody so what's
the deal he just want it's white people
that are like or what I don't understand
people on the far right that are like
it's not a Melting Pot that it's he was
saying it in a positive light right so
if he was like in his Melting Pot and I
hate that they would have liked that
well yeah but only still though don't
you think that's a fringe of people like
I it just seems like everybody's mad at
him oh sure but Twitter makes it always
seem like that right right but but a ton
of people on Twitter were ganging up on
him being like Oh we thought you were
our hero but you think America's Melting
Pot and that's a good thing so we hit
you got it yeah like a lot of Christian
nationalists because uh people were like
that because people don't like me on
Twitter but I go out on and on the
street and everyone stops me and takes
pictures and [__] did you know that
that's real life Twitter it's not real
life isn't that crazy I just someone
just did it right now it happens to me
too so it's not even a thing so I don't
even listen to No but it happened so I
don't even listen to people when they
say something to me like
I'm like oh maybe they're talking to me
and I don't know but some guy all of a
sudden I kept hearing the talking I'm
walking here I came here to talk he's
like come on man he's like I know you
heard me and I'm like oh wait what and I
turn around I love you podcast man and
I'm like oh [__] I was like he's like
can I get a picture
and I was like sure and I took a picture
and they stood there and I was like cool
well thank you man and then I walked and
I walked over here so now who's boring I
the last time someone recognized me it
was these two women and they were like
doing like this
rabbits looking at me yeah and they were
eating little pieces of lettuce
and I noticed him and I was like what do
I got like
it happens to me not enough that every
time it happens I think like I got
something on my face or something yeah I
mean it doesn't happen huh it no I just
said it I just literally just said it
does never but it doesn't happen as much
as it does to like truly famous people
because obviously I'm not that okay and
I obviously should be that I don't know
um but yeah I think I should be famous
and it turned out they they they knew I
was and they were like oh he's the
greatest I know that you think that and
a lot of people think that but I don't
think that about myself okay other a lot
of people other people think if this is
a real conversation to be the weirdest
guy they'd be like okay yeah yeah
um but yeah and I was like you guys want
a picture of me they were like yeah we
obviously do and I was like okay
wow
weirdest poses I mean you know
bad hold your tits hold your tits dude
um that was gamerville dude gamerville
so it was like my space days right that
was my space there was a guy that we saw
his profile and he was like this
gamerville and it's the the thing under
was called gamerville and everything was
game it was a has a high school picture
though which is he had a bright yellow
buttoned up collared shirt on and he was
super handsome yeah and he was like a
teenager though and he posed like this
super serious
and now gamer hey dude we can't but we
can't get out of the boringness right
now you cannot get out of the boringness
we're stuck in a [__] quicksand of
boringness this is boring as [__] dude
I'm actually getting upset how do we
make it better this podcast is right now
this episode is the legit most important
episode we've ever done out of 60
episodes I don't think so I don't I
think it's really good so far
we've been laughing we're having fun
everybody They're laughing yeah but you
think it's you I did the poses that was
good that was good but like you know
ever since nostrilisimo yeah it's been
downhill wow I guess the poses were good
nostrilysima was good yeah but come on
dude I'm getting upset man all right
well then this could start submissions I
guess so but we should be more
entertaining you want to get entertained
before we start I don't know I mean we
don't need that right no I think we're
good though I think we're being great
all right all right we're being great
all right so let's do the first one okay
here we go and here we go
hi Matt and Chris I love you
baby book Chris I saw you
saw you I just need some advice so my
brother has been dating this girl for
the past two and a half years and I just
don't like her at all
um she's very very inauthentic she tries
really really hard to get me to like her
in a in a really weird people-pleasing
way and it just rubs me the wrong way
they're around very often twice a week
and I'm just looking for some advice on
how to tolerate her
just to keep a good relationship with my
brother
um so any advice would help thank you
the only thing she said is hey guys I
need advice I don't like my brother's
girlfriend she tries to be too nice
so just based off what she said
that doesn't sound bad she's the problem
yeah no I think she buys me gifts and
she gives me massages it's really
annoying she always tells me how nice I
look number one how do I get rid of her
what I
a problem purportedly I would imagine
the way she does I I understand actually
there are people who I've known who want
me to like them so bad yeah yeah yeah it
makes me hate them well but okay but it
doesn't make you hate them or does it
just uncomfortable about them and you're
like you don't want to be around them
because that's different okay but if
it's let's say it's that it's two times
a week that's a lot it is but it sounds
like this person is a good person right
but it's still a good valid question
this really bothers her how she's
supposed to do it she's not saying like
how do I confront you said I really
don't like her is what she said fine
okay
she's being made uncomfortable by it
okay and she wants advice on how to deal
with it tell her to chill to hit look
you don't need to impress me I already
don't like it you're never gonna win me
over
Hey look
and let's move on dude and then tell my
brother gets a new girlfriend I won't be
happy so it's all good dude here's the
thing I see it twice a week what's weird
is that that actually would be the best
thing for everybody but she can't do
that because that's that would not be
the best thing that would be breaking
the social contract worst thing for
every individual no it would be the
brother would be awful she would cry no
but the person would feel bad about it
that's the first part just the first
part where you're like look you don't
have to try to impress me I don't like
you and I'm not gonna like you but
that's fine that's a hardcore dude we
could we could just tolerate each other
everything will be great you don't have
to try to make me like you I don't and
I'm not gonna that would make things
better two envelopes slide one over to
her
don't like you slide another one over
sure not gonna why why do the envelopes
because it's so hardcore if you give me
a hardcore be so hardcore is it like it
should be personalized stationary too it
should be like a really beautiful
writing and like a hearts and stuff so
it like oh this is sweet you know don't
like it
and then and then not gonna and and the
the disrespect of not even referring to
the first card is the best for the
second card oh I have a good I think you
should have a third one what when she
reads the second one she's obviously
gonna have some kind of reaction yeah
yeah yeah you just say like something
yeah and then you just go uh
slide over the third one and then and
the third she opens the third one and
says don't bother
don't waste your breath is even better
actually uh
just
just do you love your brother yes then
like it's fine dude she's just you're
with her twice do you see her twice a
week yeah but if you really want like
tips on how to handle it dude
haven't you experienced life all you got
to do is smile nod and then like turn
and talk to somebody else two times a
week is a lot it is but like you
obviously don't want to listen to her
for the sake of your brother is this a
deal with it situation is this a hey
deal with it the advice is dealing deal
with it I mean kinda but just like
only because
look if you don't really have a great
relation with your brother then all bets
are off let loose and let it fly and let
her rip and let them have it and let it
all hang out okay you know so much and
let's get it on baby baby you know so
that's not right all right you want to
[__] no no like let's get it on like
let's fight
um let's get it on dude and then let's
get ready to rumble I hate you hey I
hate you so disgusting doing this for my
brother uh because ew uh
yeah deal with it that's my favorite
thing I do here's my name here's my
advice grow up no rate my hair
quick rate my hair eight
really
dude seven
um
it's pretty good today really it's
pretty good yeah it's good today yeah
Marco
that's as good as it looks
so has always hated your hair no that's
has always wanted to tell you he hates
your hair but couldn't because we're
live now had an opportunity so he said
something that wasn't dishonest no no
let me say that again okay that's the
best
hang on what am I trying to say that's
the best your hair can look
that's the best version of your head no
I think it's so dead still rude still so
wait this is the best my hair can look
yeah in a but the way you're saying it
sounds so bad no it sounds like you're
dealing with a [__] of hair and he's
just like you do it you're making the
best of what yeah that is yeah yeah that
is hot outside hey it's what it is
all right well okay all right so 10 out
of 10 for my hair but not 10 out of 10
for hair that's the [__] up part right
all right whatever right 10 or 10 for
your hair four out of ten
for hair it doesn't even get onto the
actual right what do you call it rating
system when it comes to Just Hair okay
all right all right all right next one
next one
just
show them what the gym has made for you
know what I'm saying bro this guy's so
nervous
seriousness
it could be from Lord of the Rings
obviously this guy is nervous and this
is the way but he has Lord of the Rings
face right yo Matt yo Chris
what's good
just show them what the gym has made for
you know what I'm saying all right yeah
I do but uh
but for real in all seriousness uh
recently
I went to a drive-through to pick up
some food
and there was a girl at the
drive-through window who was pretty cute
and I wanted to just kind of give her a
compliment I'm just being like hey
you're really pretty or whatever
and as she was handing me my food I was
like hey you're super cute like I was
like uh thank you for the food uh by the
way you're super cute or whatever and
immediately she was like oh okay or like
not like that it was more like
it was just kind of like a like okay
like I want to leave kind of thing and
like she wanted to kind of close the
drive-through window
it was just a really weird response
and I was like really confused because I
was like I don't think I was being weird
about it and I was like sorry I don't
I'm not trying to be weird I just wanted
to compliment or whatever and then she
was like all right all right and like
just like see it and I was like okay
like enjoy your food let's see bye you
know it was just very weird yeah
um sounds like it he was native I guess
I'm just wondering he's like am I the
one being weird was she weird with her
reaction
um are compliments like that like
like can you give compliments like that
where you're just kind of straight up
[Music]
um
does the context matter
or something like that do you think it's
weird I just I would like to get your
guys General uh thoughts on compliments
as a whole like how you would go about
that and stuff like that so anyway I
don't know uh thanks so much for your
guys's podcast it's awesome thanks bro
and uh yeah I'll see you later thanks
Manchester trailing off you're a good
guy yeah I don't feel like I don't feel
like that's weird at all oh thanks oh
you're super cute by the way it's not
weird but it's totally understandable
that it would make her uncomfortable you
never know yeah yeah no that's true
because you don't know about she
obviously you know her dad died early
and maybe she has a lot of trauma but
like you have no idea what someone else
is going through you have no idea like
the experience she's having of you doing
that she could have just had something
bad happen right before yeah true who
the hell knows what if you found out
that the place was actually in the
process of getting robbed and he had no
idea afterwards that's why she was so
weird he would be like oh I feel better
now and he wouldn't care that got robbed
you know yeah yeah yeah but
look these things happen and you gotta
the best advice I got ever got about
stuff like this you have a bad
experience in life that isn't that
meaningful but it affects you in a way
that you kind of Can't Let It Go not me
think of it like toilet paper
you'd wipe your ass with it you wipe
your ass with it one time wow it's got
[__] on it and what do you do you flush
it down the toilet you don't think about
that and you don't wipe again it's just
gone you wipe one time and then you're
done uh no but like it it it's in your
past it is done it was a weird clunky
awkward thing how it happened it's good
though it's not indicative of how it's
going to happen in the future it's not
indicative of what you did that
warranted the weird feelings that Rose
after she said what she said it's
nothing it's it's nothing it just
happened and life goes on so it I get
what you're where you're coming from
like did I do it weird was it wrong was
it wrong no no no unless you did it
weird but it doesn't sound like you did
but like people are gonna react weird
sometimes when you comment on their
physical appearance even if it's a good
thing especially women because women
ostensibly especially in this case if
she's a as you say cute girl she
probably gets it a lot and doesn't know
what to do with it especially at work it
makes sense dude like you guys to just
it's honor it's it's not weird that you
did it but it you got to accept the
reaction you're gonna get if you're
gonna go out on a limb like that yeah
yeah but it's fine who cares yeah yeah
who cares I would have doubled down what
what's up with the weirdness oh wow
you're cute can I get a straw
yeah you're really cute by the way he
didn't even [__] describe what she
did well at all because you know it was
worse than what he was I know that I
know that he was like hey you're cute
and she was like okay well she was like
her and then like it was kind of weird
and then I said oh uh just was saying
you're cute don't want to be weird and
then she was like or uh you know and
then I don't know and just end it dude
she was like [__] you [__] get
out of here dude when guys tell stories
and they're got really good specific
details yeah and then there's a part
where they're like it's so wishy-washy
and mushy
what do you what's the thing that
happened they either [__] up they
still do it though then when they repeat
it they're like it was like this and
you're like yeah yeah or they got their
ass handed to them their brains are like
they can't do it
yeah uh so yeah the girl obviously threw
the drink in his face and even if that
happened honestly it's fine whatever God
I wish we could like watch a video of
yes that would oh that's so free yeah my
mind doesn't even go there because I I
feel heartbroken that we can't so I mean
that's just bruh you want that so bad I
want it so bad I didn't even think of it
and now you broke my heart thank you
Marco thanks Chris hey you broke you
legitimately broke my heart by breaking
that up you're welcome I didn't even go
there thanks for uh I would could you
imagine getting to see that
could you imagine why are you laughing
it would be so upsetting it would be the
best it would be the best what if it was
a bad angle though how upsetting would
that be I would get so mad I quit the
podcast and and congratulations I would
kill just for audio of what happened
yeah for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're [__] weird dude get out no I
was just saying you're cute get out
take the food and you're for it's free
go also I really wonder what he said
actually because he did why would you
get mad at that I thought she missed it
um yeah no you gotta what do you you
gotta X here's the thing for guys just
like yeah if you're gonna compliment a
woman that you don't know that's a
stranger it's you're basically
coming at it like well it's fair game I
can say what I want you got to accept
the responses that you get too if it's a
negative one then that's that's it
that's it yeah yeah but you got to just
let it go it's done that she's allowed
to do that all right yeah that's fine
but it's like why can't you say nice
tits to a girl honestly
it's kind of weird because it's overtly
sexualizing I know women don't want
strangers to come up today why are you
asking if you know I'm just saying if if
somebody came up to me and said well you
look like you got a healthy package
but I wouldn't necessarily be bothered
about that but that's because of society
no it's because that kind of thing
doesn't happen to men ever so you don't
have to worry about what the person is
thinking is exactly right oops questions
and while I'm answering you're talking
over every single word that I say but I
know that and I'm just saying that that
you shouldn't do that so you're asking
questions
but if you say bad tits that's even
worse
yeah that would be worse yeah or if
somebody came up to you and said you
look like you got a small dick
I mean that would be that would actually
be hilarious oh man
how funny would that be yeah that'd be
really good really good sir let's see if
it's small penis yeah anyway excuse me
are you in line
people say you got small dick energy you
know yeah I know but that's way
different and it looks like you have a
small penis not strangers though dude
right
uh Thomas who that's that guy's name who
okay we need we we want more specifics
honestly and when you submit it say
exactly what happened yeah what did she
do don't tiptoe around it say exactly
what happened excruciating detail yeah
excruciating for you details yeah for
you okay so shooting for you and thanks
supremely pleasurable for us yeah thank
you and congratulations on looking like
you have a face that somebody would be
in Lord of the Rings or The Hobbit so I
mean he does too it's unbelievable
because he's small looking at me no just
his face with the beard and the color of
his hair you know okay okay it's [__]
frankly goddamn annoying
cool dies in the first one cool hey guys
it's Michaela from San Diego
um I recently discovered your podcast
because I was like typing into Spotify
like life advice what do I do with my
life and it came up and I'm so happy it
did because you guys make me laugh so
hard I might have six pack from things
that you've said so well that's the
coolest thing around and I want advice
on basically my life I feel so fulfilled
I have a dream job I you know I do a
bunch of cool Hobbies give back all that
stuff has a really good Community but I
still find myself thinking all the
Timeless but what is it all for like why
are we here and so I guess am I yeah if
you have any advice on not thinking so
existentially all the time that'd be
awesome and also I'm looking for my
partner in time so if you know of any
like open-minded nature-loving goofballs
a submission that said that uh yeah but
we guarantee you guys nature lovings
we're going to get a lot of guys writing
to us on Instagram being like I'm this
can you put me in touch with her um that
I mean honestly I think that we're would
be perfect together I'm a fun-loving
goofball yeah
um okay gamer it's gamerville honestly
yeah
heartbeat dude
has been dead for 700 years
um I
I suffer sort of from the same thing or
have historically in my life me and
honestly like a reading and certain
specific kinds of books have like
quelled like that kind of anxiety and
Andromeda Strain yeah or anything about
younger no Congo yeah uh Congo for me
was a big one uh Michael Crichton no um
like particularly on the subject of
evolutionary biology Jurassic Park
because once I start to understand why
my brain works the way it does why I
think existently why on this or that or
anxious or whatever it is
and I get I can get like biological
answers it calms that those parts of my
brain down wow it seems like it would
make me way more anxious oh really
that's like I think so well no because
once you get answers you're like you're
not you're like oh wait my mind's doing
that because I guess so millions of
years of evolution we all live in a
matrix then you start thinking about
that and you're like oh [__] you know
what I mean well that only happens if
you're a [__] idiot if I'm not an
idiot and I don't do that but I'm just
saying you could okay well only idiots
are like oh oh we live in The Matrix do
you know what I mean
I do I think that we're not in the
Matrix but we could be
what do you mean by The Matrix though
we're not really living this life and
it's a simulation and we're all in
incubators and stuff and we're plugged
in okay that's what you mean sure that's
possible we could be all living in a
simulation but if you mean the Matrix
the movie no no I don't mean that
because I yeah I don't mean that because
I met Lawrence he's not Morpheus where's
Fishburne
is
a king among men he was Cowboy Curtis in
Pee-wee Herman oh he was Playhouse and
it's the coolest thing ever that he was
that and he lied
about his age to Francis Ford Coppola to
be able to get into the apocalypse now
and he has a huge role in that movie
illegally he was 16 when he did it dude
isn't that crazy what a [__] cool
thing you can do that I guess yeah dude
there's footage of him like at the table
reads and stuff he's so obviously a kid
but he successfully lied it got the role
and is amazing in it and and then he did
the major he's done so many [__] cool
things I know I didn't even know he was
I know you're listening you love this
show and I just want you to know we love
you back okay
uh yeah yeah but what about you for the
for the uh
I think that that'll probably go away a
little bit with age she seems like she's
in her early 20s and you know she's got
she's got a lot of living to do and uh I
mean that's just like what is it all for
is like that's kind of like a you don't
the the to even think that is
egotistical because it's like what is it
all for like you like you know like you
know enough about what's going on that
you get to think oh what's the grander
purpose like you might figure it out you
won't you won't but yeah sure if she's
being very egotistical
you need to be taken down a notch wow
wow uh but that's not necessarily what
she means I if if that is what you mean
yeah sure but I don't think she's like
what's the meaning of okay what's my
purpose here on Earth oh okay you don't
all right I got it I thought I heard it
as more of a broader question like what
is all this what's going on around us
why is are things the way that they are
it's you'll never know did I remember
the very first time I looked into the
sky and realized the epicness of space
not time and I it was it wasn't my first
true anxiety attack but it was like the
beginning of me being on the way to
getting anxiety yes not me I was with
Nick Marquand
shout out to Nick Marquan oh boy Nick
and we were at a lookout we weren't
being gay but it was just us so far
sounds gay we were just kids we were
drinking beer looking up at the sky and
I'm telling Nick like and then I'm
starting to feel like so overwhelmed and
he was like yeah me too kiss me and then
we made out and swore we would never
talk about it again and I didn't believe
him so I threw him off the cliff and
killed him wait but oh wow okay well I
guess I haven't seen him in a long time
yep
of course when he would root for the
Raiders oh come on readers yeah okay and
he had a dog named me he had a dog did
you just fart well Me Shaggy you
Chris just farted no or me how do you
know
Donald Trump uh
yeah he had a dog named Rocky he loved
the Raiders
[Music]
it was cool he was the man dude he had a
Ned Flanders like Mustang he was never
playing one time years later I saw him
without the mustache and I was like this
is not working were things not going for
him I don't want to look at you what do
you mean this is like shaved this is the
gum man no it's like a white liberators
or aren't even they're not even with us
anymore yeah he they're Oakland he was
at a wedding and he just looks it was
like you're not you get the mustache
back we'll talk wow my friend's dad will
talk my friends dads it when I was in
high school honestly every single
goddamn one of them yeah if they walked
in a room yeah and said hi yeah I'm one
of your friends in high school's dad
which one am I okay I would have no idea
I'd have never seen my friend's dads in
high school well really because they
would be home once or twice no I don't
know like you have I remember your
friend's dad oh I see I don't remember
my friend's dad's dude I don't have a
clue who they are you had a really weird
I did assembly of friends like Morgan
daisaki yeah but also even the regular
ones I wouldn't know their [__] faces
their dad's Dave meeting who what's his
dad look like
I don't know Josh Oakley what's his dad
look like I don't know
they're your friends you should that's
what I'm saying yeah yeah hi I'm one of
your friend's dad from high school what
Am I who am I I go like this uh and run
away well lucky for you that's never
gonna happen yeah it comes up to you and
he's like Dave meaning he's dead you
were friends with my son in high school
I'm their dad who am I where's game show
you know no one does that uh Josh ER
oh four people in the audience is all
his family
oh
all right um
no he died a long time ago oh okay
this is the saddest game show it's also
six minutes you know
it's how I couldn't be more than two one
or two episodes you know you would need
like 30 like 12 dads to fill a hole and
that would be one shot yeah and then and
then I would not have any more Morgan
dozaki's dad oh I would know him he's
Japanese that's Morgan dozaki's dad
right do you know what he looked like no
but I would say I don't have one
Japanese sure yeah yeah okay okay anyway
that's cheating but yeah not really I'm
very eclectic with my friends all right
next one
what's up Matt what's up Chris
um I'm a newlywed I've been married for
a month now congrats and um so pretty
much
I do all the cooking which is fine
because I've grown up cooking and I'm a
little bit better about it and it's kind
of what I do
but my wife will almost uh maybe once a
week twice a week she'll have these
Pinterest recipes and she insists on
trying them wow and
um they're awful
and um
how do you navigate telling her hey I
appreciate this meal that you just spent
an hour cooking but
now I need to go to uh Taco Bell to eat
something for dinner because that was
awful so yeah let me start not saying
that how I should handle this I wish you
said
um appreciate it if you guys end up hit
to it
died died
appreciate it if you guys end up
we say if you guys end up
oh my God
uh honey I made chicken Parma
so you're kind of you're kind of in a
bad situation my friend it's actually
man I gotta tell you something I I I've
never really thought about this because
Kristen is she cooks I wish you cooked
more she's great but you you gotta like
that's got to be horrible because
they're doing something so beautiful and
so nice I mean that's awesome if you
have somebody in your home that cooks
for you whether or not whoever it is
that's awesome home-cooked meals are the
[__] of course you know
um and and if
she's doing it look he likes to cook and
all that but like he gets two nights off
because she's gonna do the pinch of [__]
and then they're just dog [__] how are
you that bad if you're following the
recipes yeah that is pretty weird it
sounds like he could be a little bit
like why don't you cook yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah that's a great advice T helper
do it and also you'll be like you'll get
points for being like
someone who helps your partner everyone
wants helps cooking dude you know what
here's the deal this is great
she wants to be a take care she wants to
take care of you or the family whatever
it is dude you come in you help her
she's gonna feel so connected to you
you're not even gonna get the meal made
because you're gonna end up making love
oh my God yep put a little bit of spices
in there and I'm not there
so start
uh
what was that putting all the stuff away
a mime just a mime clothes in the oven
and turning it off and okay
okay well uh oh and then in the bed
later oh man too bad we missed out on
cooking things oh let's get Taco Bell
but I want you got and it might be hard
to handle Montage eating Taco Bell and
the flame Burns a candle no no no and
then candle feeds a flame oh God
[__] talk about this oh yeah we're
making our dreams
you know I guess I know
wow yeah I mean Taco Bell dude you're
gross I don't trust your tasting food
anymore I don't I question everything
this guy said now you want to go to Taco
Bell
almost any sure any home-cooked meal is
better than Taco Bell I'm just gonna go
out on a limb the Mexican pizza there
is a one-way ticket to diorissimo okay
all right man you know
one-way ticket to diarrhea here's the
deal it's not this show really shaped up
to be a good show I mean yeah but
um it's just so
but I mean you better use the when you
do the clip Anthony when you better when
you do the thing where it's like hey
this happens in on the episode you
better do the [__] Taco Bell thing
because that's the thing that'll really
grab people's attention and then we
start getting boring and then we get
back into it I don't know if I agree
okay just if I saw like a teaser of
someone just like pretending this [__]
really aggressively I might not keep
watching
you know you're acting like it's like a
mega Surefire way to get eyeballs you
know I'm just saying what's the one
thing people love more than anything
people acting like they're aggressively
[__] the trailer to quiz show that
[__] that movie you know oh man quiz
Show's a good movie thanks for bringing
it up man I didn't I didn't see it I I
saw it a long time ago in the theater
what I saw with you yep yeah and Mom and
Dad loved it they really did yeah and I
loved it too
now we're back to boring okay let's go
hey Matt hey Chris Halen here I need
some advice I'm currently moving out of
my rental right now and buying my first
house oh yeah dude super nervous and
exciting yeah
um what uh my question is we are
planning on painting the exterior of the
house
so would you guys recommend doing it
yourself or hiring someone I know it can
cost a lot to have someone come do it
yeah but at the same time doing it
yourself is gonna be a pain what do you
guys think thank you I actually
interestingly enough just looked into
what it costs to potentially paint
a house
yeah I was gonna say my house but I
didn't want people to know I have a
house
but now they do okay uh and it's so
expensive but yeah the paint a house is
so the outside of it well yeah okay yeah
I mean have you looked at have you ever
no I like all the colors of my house
okay well
says so much money but then if you think
about it you're like I guess of course
it has to be yes but it's really
expensive so unless
your house looks like [__] he wants to
paint it right you want to paint it dude
should I do it himself he says I mean
that's
I don't think leave it you know what
dude honestly leave it for a few years
until you're freaking balled and then
hire the guys but maybe I mean he bought
a house he's gonna have some money
he bought a house yeah some kids how
much is it to paint a house hire some
that's a good idea how much is it that
is a good idea why is there ever been kg
about how much of it why because what'd
you say I said that's a terrible idea
why are kids yeah I don't mean
eight-year-olds kids yeah how do I do it
some high school kids they only paint a
they only paint up to the bot like five
feet up
tell them to watch some YouTube videos
yeah about technique and then [__] oh
hold on hold on all you need to do is
watch Karate Kid first of all second of
all how much does it cost to paint a
house why is everybody being so good
depends in the house obviously okay 25
Grand
what exactly yeah I know it's crazy holy
[__] yeah it's crazy but then start to
think about it then it's like okay it's
a lot of work many hours a lot of people
just to color though what color is his
house is what I wanna oh it's just run
down he's saying yeah it doesn't matter
what color the color isn't what costs
money if you want a pink that'll be 35
Grand if you want it white that's just
eight grand no that's not how it works I
know that you didn't know you didn't
know that until I said so what I'm
saying is I thought that it was a bad
color and he wanted to repaint it but in
actuality it just needs another paint
job yeah if it's a bad color just keep
it if it is falling apart it's
depressing and you need to fix it no
matter what it comes true you can have
something at your home or or in your
home or on your property just be
straight up depressing and if a paint
job is is shitty and [__] up and worn
you you got to fix it it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what it costs you
gotta do interesting so I would say save
your if you paint it you're probably
gonna have it have it painted in the
next year or two anyway because you're
not going to do a great job unless you
are a painter which obviously you're not
otherwise you wouldn't be asking this
question you might just do it a house
major so get it hire someone
and get it done
yeah just yeah because honestly part of
the cost of the house hire someone and
get it done or just don't do it yes yeah
I agree don't [__] hire Anthony kids
or whatever the [__] Anthony kids do not
hire Anthony kids no Marco said I don't
know who said it but I said and I agree
with that that's terrible that you're
just gonna redo it it's gonna look bad
it's gonna look bad if they do it too
though what do you mean if they
themselves do it yeah yeah that too yeah
yeah yeah just just hire someone that's
the cost of the house I like that think
of it like yeah lump it in with the cost
the down payment it's the cost house
check out these dude it's also doing
business hey those are good I never like
you like these yeah you always like my
shoes the colorway is amazing yeah well
you like these the gray and the pink is
always going to be a good thing for me
all right would you say that's pink that
is pink yeah I looked at it more like a
beige thing but okay I guess you're
right beige
that's pink okay what what I mean am I
crazy no you're not crazy I'm agreeing
with you oh okay
beige though it's like saying like it
could also be
it looks a little no no no it looks a
little muted pink but yeah I love muted
muted pink is the way to go though all
right hot pink kind of sucks
Barbie bombed all right next one
yo what's good Chris and Matt you know
Sundays used to just be Sundays but now
they [__] rip dude okay so anyway a
guy I work with
showed up to work a few months ago maybe
like six months ago
extremely religious over a weekend you
know and ever since then he's been
telling me oh dude you're gonna go to
hell and I feel really bad because I
don't want that to happen to you and I'm
gonna hope that you get saved because I
don't want you to go to hell and he says
this like every day oh god what the [__]
do I say I need something better than ah
yeah no no that's real I need something
good so
let me know dude how annoying is it that
these people go through their [__] and
then real and then think something and
then they bother
you
about it all the time and now you have
to deal with it because they did
something and changed their minds dude
that is so maddening hey man you did
this you deal with it I don't want to
[__] think about this congratulations
for your good time
stop talking about I'm not go [__]
yourself that's so annoying here's the
problem the root of the problem is that
a lot of well religion I was gonna say
Christianity a lot of branches of
Christianity but a lot of religions in
general consider it their
Soul Purpose while they're living on
Earth to spread word and convert people
that's why Judaism in an objective way
is the best religion they're not doing
that at all it doesn't say anywhere in
their text nor do the peop the people
who are Jewish try to get that's right
there's only 14 million of them I mean
that's one reason they don't evangelize
I know but that's what the best thing
about it I know it's an elite club dude
we can't get into they well you can they
just don't get into it they aren't on
the streets like this [__] you could
walk around and be like uh hello where
is the Jewish Center they don't want you
to go to hell you know they won't give
it to you you could have matzah you get
everything but I swear I'm Jewish and
they're like what was your mom she was
Christian all right well you're not
Jewish no you can be you can be Jewish
can't get in you can be Jewish
always if you just convert to Judas yeah
convert yeah you're just wrong I know
but you know what uh just tell the guy
here do say like man I really want to
save you you should be Christian do that
just this was you man really I don't
want you to go to hell I don't want to
see that happen to you I care about you
so I want you to be Christian uh okay
I'm Christian
okay great I I did it thank you thanks
man yeah done yeah that's good yeah yeah
also you don't have to worry about lying
well because you're not you don't
believe in having our health the thing
you have to be careful of is that then
he probably will want to talk to you
about all then at least but no that's
not fun he doesn't want to talk you can
make it a thing for yourself though
you're like oh man it's an awesome oh
God you know they die for all our sins
oh yeah dude that was so cool that's
crazy man if you really read into it you
can read a whole bunch of stuff and it
just learned so much but what you could
also say is
listen the amount that you want me to be
Christian is the amount I want you to
stop
telling me to be Christian so what are
we going to do here what we're going to
do here is you're going to stop
or else I'm gonna [__] kill you okay
well that's my advice to you all right
that's what he said yeah as he's being
choked
all right
hey Chris and Matt big fans especially
you Chris you're my boy
stand up of all your stuff dude Matt
you're cool too again I don't accept it
basically I've Got A Sitch with my
girlfriend
um turns out she likes girls and I'm
super supportive obviously and I'm proud
that she came out and told me about it
but it hurt because I felt like I was
doing something wrong but after some
talking we realized no it's just
something that obviously she can't help
and nothing really
sort of woke that up in her that's just
how she is I love her the same I
actually though want your guys advice on
am I an [__] if I want to still try
to make it work with her what because
she's kind of my everything and I can't
really imagine life without her
um
do you think there's a way we could stay
together
even though now I know that she likes
girls
it's a tough one and if you guys think I
should just break up too let me know
anyways love the show so much keep
rocking it you guys are awesome what's
tough about that does she still love you
dude this is the greatest thing that's
ever happened to this guy what the [__]
was that oh that's a hero but no but
like what is the well he's saying I
don't love you I only I'm sure that's
different then obviously you shouldn't
be with her if she's like a [__]
idiot well she's gonna break up with you
but also if she's saying I also like
women but I my feelings for you haven't
changed then obviously you stay with her
you
[__] idiot now why am I being so hard
on you because you said you threw me
some [__] scraps at the top you're
like oh man I like you too it was really
just about [__] Chris so I'm gonna
treat you with the amount of shittiness
you treated me you're a [__] idiot
either way now go ahead
um so so overboard um said you're pretty
cool you know like yeah that's not the
opposite of you saying don't don't throw
me some [__] scraps okay so yeah she
likes girls so what so what it doesn't
mean she doesn't want to be with you if
she doesn't want to be with you then
she'll break up with you don't worry
about breaking up with her yeah dude
what are you talking about second of all
third of all whatever I'm at dude uh
does she want to have fun with other
girls and you right
blind blind absolutely completely blind
hey dude I'm sorry but
yeah I mean this guy's calling with
without a problem yeah dude hey dude I
don't know what's going on man I got so
much [__] it's crazy uh it's just
falling out of my [__] pockets and
[__] I don't know how to do it I'm
trying to collect it but do you have any
containers uh what containers I should
use I should go to The Container Store
but I don't understand what's going on I
got too much [__] around I keep coming
I keep [__] and uh I make so much
money
what's up dude beanie dump what's up
what's up
that's dumb but the last the assembly
line of people just sitting with naked
and waiting to have sex with them they
could say dude
it would be so actually hectic if that
was your thing now
what is he saying if we had to guess
what are you talking about guy uh he is
saying
he doesn't understand what what it's
like he's like he doesn't get it you
know what he it is he doesn't
he don't got it like that right so
you're good there's what you go oh hey
I'm dating a girl for a while oh hey
guess what hey hey I like girls I go
like this cool mommy who cares you're
leaving me no cool mommy you like girls
me too but guess what I'm with you yeah
that's exactly the way to think about it
like you want to introduce yourself so
do I I'm only with one can you only be
with one yep great nothing changed
we're inviting everybody over for the
nothing change
wow status quo exactly status quo
nothing changed at all
wow yeah
taking it so far the poppers you know
popper popper sock ploppers one I know
because they don't go for yeah and they
go they go like this
dude how about what you just did for
some reason reminded me of gender reveal
parties yeah well I hate him they had me
do one on cameo
hate him the drive by hate him hate him
they had him they had they come back to
make sure you they know I hit him I did
a uh I did a gender reveal for on Cameo
it's pretty cool what was cool about it
well I just I felt honored that they
asked me to reveal there I was revealing
it for their party that's cool but
gender reveal parties no no I know I
know I know yeah
because like also there's always the
every time I see one not every time but
like every three or four there's always
one parent that's upset about the gender
and it's like well don't do it if you're
rooting for one yeah you got to be
excited about it either way uh also
gives [__] I I I I I don't I don't know
gives a [__] dude what about the gender
of your Social you care
but like you once you know you love the
baby anyway yeah you're like oh no no no
I I was honestly if it was going to be a
either one if they're gonna be a girl I
would Justice happen like I can't
imagine being like once you know and
then it becomes real for you because
once you know it becomes real for you
right like you're like oh hey it's gonna
be a boy oh it's gonna be a girl then
you think the next thought is oh my God
I'm gonna love that boy girl whatever it
is so much it's not no I wanted a boy I
can't that I can't wrap my head right
you know I know people do that he is
that who gonna rule the bleep Kingdom so
um
yeah it's a election
um yeah but I I can't believe
that people do that but they do it's
funny that gender reveal the rise of
gender reveal parties has coincided with
also the belief that gender is a
construct and not a real thing well
that's it's like why right it's just
funny though it's like yeah those both
can't be true What's Happening Here Yeah
I know what's going on here what's going
on
uh should we try to do one more or no
[Music]
Korean company hello hello
um let
him from jump since like the rest of
Justin Bieber was that you're taping a
fan on fire in Vancouver I really saw
you in Seattle in February not you're
the one period of the story anyway what
I would love your guys's help with is
the fact that I have a friend who's
constantly meeting the love of her life
like she will meet a guy and within a
matter of weeks be like he is the one
we're getting married this is my
soulmate and then when it inevitably
doesn't work out
um they're picking up the pieces with
her and working through what that looks
like talking to her everyday
consoling her and then in a matter of
weeks after that she'll meet someone and
go on one date and be like you're not
gonna believe this but I believe it
we're getting married and I'm not being
hyperbolic this is seriously how she
responds to every single man and it's up
and down and up and down and I love her
and I want to be supportive but I'm
tired of taking this ride with her so
what do you guys think I should do
I fully
understand what's going on here oh oh no
I fully like can relate to her
experience of what's going on oh
I know people like this it is so
so frustrating and annoying and you ha
you have to they might not make a
difference because they're probably
still gonna do it yeah but you have to
say
sort of like not aggressively but
emphatically
you say this about everyone and then
when it inevitably which it of course it
is inevitable it inevitably becomes not
true reveals itself to be not true
and you set yourself up to be super
upset and you're doing that for a very
avoidable reason you need to stop
projecting the future that you desire on
every single partner you meet because
it's probably just by way of regular how
things always work out with people it's
probably not going to work out with that
one guy take it slow avoid pain that
you're basically directly causing
yourself yeah stop doing that to
yourself preach okay yeah I don't do
that but I'm done uh I feel like that's
horseshit honestly no no what you said
is dead right let's preach you gotta
stop it's like dude
honestly at some point
well obviously you loved a friend and
this is just one of the shortcomings and
it's not like a make or break thing but
yeah you gotta just be like yo you do
this all the time you know and please
stop doing it because I I'm wasting
we're wasting a bunch of time here yeah
that's good too and also she
she's got a lot of problems she should
go to therapy she got a lot of problems
like she got like a real [__] like
she's codependent probably and you know
what I mean if that's how it is when you
meet somebody and it's how do you like
that many people by the way I know
that's the craziest I know I know I know
I know like I don't I meet people that
go like this show me you don't suck
oh like that's the default right like
nah I'm actually not like that that
someone's worth your time right not like
in a dick way but like you don't just
like why don't you tell her hey you're
worth more than this [__] like don't you
don't need to fall in love with all
these guys you're better than that I
believe in you and you may not because
deep down you know you're you're looking
for a man so hard and also her energy
tell her that her energy that she's
giving off to you is definitely the
energy that the guy's feeling and that's
what's chasing him away yeah yeah she
got to take a deep breath know that love
will come but it's not Whitney Houston
it's not like
every new guy you meet you got to stop
projecting your fantasy onto him like
let that come to you and it's okay if
you meet a guy and it isn't your fantasy
and it isn't great in fact that's much
more likely so why not in the beginning
tell yourself that remind yourself of
that and let yourself not be so
devastated if it doesn't work out yeah
yeah you know what the problem with
people like this is and I'm just warning
you there are a lot of people like this
they don't whether they realize it or
not they don't want to change they want
to the drama to be high they want the
stakes to be high right they want the
high of oh I met the love of my life and
they want the low of the love of my life
ruined everything for me and you're
never going to change them I'm not
saying that is what your friend is but
don't
like you're gonna have to say something
and when you do and you don't see
anything materialized you don't see your
friend change at all don't be
disappointed and definitely don't be
surprised it's very likely that they're
doing it because somewhere deep inside
them they want to addicted to the drama
yeah to part yep
thanks for that okay uh yeah there you
go and I appreciate y'all I'll be in
Vancouver next year so be on the lookout
great even though you're the summer in
Seattle
um all right well that's good listen you
want to go to Lifeline luxury and watch
our uh show Lifeline luxury go to
patreon.com life Lifeline luxury I'm on
tour I will be in uh Virginia Richmond
Richmond Virginia and uh a bunch of
different places Pittsburgh reading
um Philadelphia go to Cleveland Detroit
chrisley.com and then uh
you know uh what else we got going on
you leave a comment please that's good
for the algorithm and then go to watch
lifeline.com to click in and do send us
a submission we love that and if you
want one-on-one advice sessions with
Matt right here go to matdalia.com you
zoom with them and hit that merch button
lifelinemirch.com thank yous very much
get every item of the merch or I don't
love you
[Music]